hey everyone at CR thread sterner Sarang
calm and in this video I want to
demonstrate how to perform hand hygiene
by using soap and water there are two
ways a nurse can perform hand hygiene
one way is through using soap and water
and another way is through using an
alcohol-based hand rub so when do you
want to perform hand hygiene you would
always want to perform hand hygiene
before and after patient care after
coming into contact was like a body
fluid or an open womb or touching
something close to the patient like a
bedside table the hand railing on the
bed or after removing your gloves before
eating and after using the bathroom now
when would you use soap and water versus
the alcohol-based hand rubs
well according to CDC Gove's guidelines
you would use soap and water when your
hands are visibly dirty after known or
suspected exposure to Clostridium
difficile which is c-diff if your
facility is experiencing an outbreak or
higher endemic rates after known or
suspected exposure to patients with
infectious diarrhea during norovirus
outbreaks
if exposure to bacillus anthracis is
suspected or proven which is anthrax
before eating and after using a restroom
so now I'm going to demonstrate how to
perform hand hygiene using soap and
water so first you need your supplies of
course you need soap you need some paper
towels and you need running water
now faucets vary depending on where you
work some are automate oh you just have
to swipe your hand underneath the water
will come on or you use a petal or it
has little faucet handles that you have
to use to turn on and off now generally
it's best not to wear jewelry during
patient care because that jewelry can
Harbor germs in some areas in the
hospital like surgery for instance
actually prohibits a person from wearing
jewelry all together but usually on some
units you can wear like a simple wedding
band so if you do wear a wedding band
and you're wearing it during patient
care you need to keep that wedding band
on whenever you're performing hand
hygiene because you want to
clean it because underneath that ring it
can Harbor germs as well so first what
we're going to do is we're going to turn
on our water and we want our water to be
warm not too hot because if it's too hot
that can dry out the skin and that can
cause you to get cracks in your skin be
really uncomfortable for you so make
sure it's warm and you want to be
careful not to let your scrubs or
anything like that touch the inside of
the sink because it's very dirty and
you'll become contaminated so once your
water is warm you want to wet your wrist
and your hands and be sure you have your
hands lower than your elbows because we
don't want the germs that are already on
our dirty hands to travel up our arms
after you've wet your hands you want to
put the soap on your hands and you're
going to put about 1 teaspoon of soap
which equals about 5 milliliters and a
lot of soap dispensers are automative
and they give you the amount of soap you
need so we're gonna take that soap and
we're going to lather our hands and our
wrists with the soap now we want to
scrub and what we're gonna do is we're
going to scrub this up on our hands
using circular motions because this is
going to help remove those germs and the
things that are sticking to our hands
and we want to cover all the areas of
our hands especially those small
crevices because that's where bacteria
likes the high we're gonna do this for
20 seconds so first we're going to go
and scrub our palms of our hands notice
I'm doing a circular motion then we're
going to get the back of our hands and
do both using those circular motions
then we're going to do our thumbs and
we're going to do each finger
individually making sure we are getting
around the fingernail area as well and
then you want to get those knuckles so
really rub the knuckles up against your
opposite hand it's also going to get the
outside of that finger now
as well then we want to get in between
our fingers because again germs love to
hide in little crevices that are hard to
get to so we make sure we get that then
we're going to pay attention to our
fingernails and we're gonna take our
hand we're gonna go to the opposite hand
and we're gonna just get underneath the
fingernail right in there just scrape
around remove any germs that could be
underneath those fingernails then what
we're going to do is we're going to get
our wrists and go about one inch above
the wrists as well now we are ready to
rinse the soap off so we're just going
to put our hands underneath the water
and let the water go downward we don't
want it to go upward rinsing all of the
soap off from the wrists down to the
fingertips once you get them rinsed you
want to take your paper towel and you're
just going to Pat your hands dry you
don't want to scrub your hands with this
paper towel because that can damage that
top layer of skin and we're going to
discard this wet paper towel then we're
going to grab a dry paper towel and turn
off our faucet and being careful not to
touch the faucet with our clean hands
and then we're going to discard this as
well now we wouldn't have used our wet
paper towel to turn off the faucet
because the germs that are on the
outside of the faucet could have
transferred through that wet paper towel
and got onto our hands and undone the
job of what we just done with cleaning
our hands okay so that wraps up this
video on how to perform hand hygiene
using soap and water thank you so much
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos